لم يضيف الكثير على طريق مصر القديم وتوفي
في سن صغيره الا ان نكتشف مقبرته كامله
وسليمه جعل منه الفرعون الاشهر في التاريخ
ابن اخناتون الذي وصل الى العرش وهو في سن
التاسعه وتوفي بعد عشر سنوات يحتفل بمرور
100 عام على اكتشاف مقبرته مقبره هي اغنى
ماورثه المصريون عن اسلافهم القدماء وهي
ايضا اهم واكتشافات الفرعونيه على الاطلاق
واكثر المواقع الاثريه زياره في العالم
هي مقبره ملكيه امضى عالم الاثار
البريطاني هورت كارتر خمس سنوات للبحث
عنها ليجدها صدفه في نوفمبر من عام
1922 وبها اكثر من 5000 قطعه اثريه كنوز
ذهبيه لم تمس ولم يسبق لها مثيل الحفرون
المصريون امضوا اشهر طويله للوصول الى باب
اول ثم 16 درجه ثم باب ثاني ليجد كارتر
الملك يقطع داخل اربعه توابيت مذهبه
ويرتدي القناع الذهبي
افخر سوري
من وجه المومياء وكانت النتيجه بكل بساطه
تدمير الجمجمه
توفي شريك هورت كارتر ومات رجل اعمال اخر
زاره المقبره معه بالاضافه الى موت مفاجئ
لاخصائي الاشعه الذي كان يفحص المومياء
فولدت اسطوره اللعنه الفراعنه التي زادت
من شغف محبي التاريخ لاسرار الفراعنه
مصر لكنني سازورها قريبا جدا
الاخيره الى باريس في 2019 كانت اخر
جولاته دوليه عاد بعدها الى القاهره ليعرض
في المتحف المصري الجديد
ويمكن في موطنه الاصلي الى الابد هذه
المره